[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qui vous amène ici ce
soir je suis consultant en art c'est
quoi exactement
willy sutton cambrioleurs de banques
accompli et maître de l'évasion
pourquoi brac est il des banques
s'étonne répondu parce que c'est là où
est l'argent
[Musique]
si ce taux n'avait vécu à notre époque
il n'aurait pas cambrioler les banques
il aurait braqué les riches je suis très
impressionné bingo je vais pas faire ça
toute ma vie je vais en faire de plus
après fini mat c'est adorable mon père
était en compte avec moi pendant
longtemps eu la nette impression que tu
essaies de nettoyer les maires de papa
c'est en séries je crois que c'est dans
l'autre sens je voulais demander qu'est
ce que tu me racontes et bien je veux en
être moi c'est marguerite
je m'appelle car élise amusez vous bien
les enfants
[Musique]
c'est un couple si adore
merci pourquoi vous étiez fbi en trois
ans vous et vos hôtes vous avez récolté
plus de 75 millions de dollars en
vendant sur le marché gris de fruits au
mollet qu'est ce que vous voulez c'est
un gros tu me fais un dernier job un
truc facile et ce sera fini toi et moi
on sera guide c'est quoi tes options mes
options sont mourir ou une pas mourir ok
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un truc que
tu me dis pas d'une nonne vous ferez une
connerie
ça sera peut-être pas vous souviendra
peut-être d'une très instable copines ou
d'or petit frère bipolaire mais il y a
toujours une faille
qu'est ce que tu penses de faire une
minute de silence
[Musique]
elle va durer combien de temps tu as
minutes là dessus
tu veux parler d'argent avec moi ça
c'est moi pédales
peta ailleurs bordeaux et les chaussures
mais redoublement donne peut-être pas
l'air mais je suis une arnaqueuse la
besoin bien jamais je suis sympa je suis
fan libye
je me fais d'état que tu dis si tu te
promets que je te défonce ta sale gueule
c'est pas si mal on n'a pas les moyens
de payer ça il faut arrêter d'essayer
d'être moins pauvres j'ai trouvé le
moyen de devenir riche
quelle est la différence entre une [ __ ]
et un connecteur de dette j'adore ces
plaques
une tuile prends ton fric avant te
fourrer d'accords collectifs péter
supplier pour soulager les gens ouvrent
grand vos oreilles de corps nouveau
numéro un c'est un sentiment
extraordinaire de trouver enfin sa vraie
vocation soldé votre tête peuvent faire
baisser votre stress et provoqué une
montée de lait pour nourrir votre bébé
il était temps de voler de mes propres à
l'ept voyait toujours plus grand plus
grands j'avais transformer la tête en
profite alléluia on reste watchers
ses stats est l'enfoiré se chie dessus
parce qu'ils savent qu'on va les battre
on va la faire fermer leurs boutiques
c'est la guerre
tapant dû te casses des mamans qui prône
sheller du genre de femme qui cherche à
se caser plus stressés
il voulait la guerre j'allais la gagner
sans menace sans intimidation
[Musique]
vais retourner en prison
non
[Musique]
pourquoi vous ne m'aviez pas parler de
ce petit ans
[Musique]
vingt mille dollars c'est ce que je vous
donnais ce foutu et ma femme
tenez on dirait que vous allez tourner
de l'oeil je vous ai observés çà c'est
le destin
l'ouragan choisi est passé en catégorie
3 et s'attaque à la côte du golfe
vous feriez mieux de vous mettre à
l'aise toutes les preuves vous désigne
comme coupable est vite mois ce qui
s'est passé je suis innocent je jure
alors c'est vrai votre femme ne vous
traite pas comme elle devrait
même s'il nous faut être complètement
fou
je sais que vous pouvez la faire
la vie sans une touche d'amour en rire
du tout
elle est dangereuse
m
alors me faire confiance la côte
vous pensez que l'amérique n'ait pas
commis ce meurtre alors t'as qu'à aller
visiter la cave
de quoi tu parles
tu vas adorer
[Musique]
tha
je sais comment jouer à ce jeu là comme
dans la vie il faut prévoir les qu il ne
s'agit pas de savoir où on en est je ne
peux pas répondre à vos questions en
même temps mais de savoir où on en sera
dans dix co ou dix ans
une crise cardiaque comme ans a pu lui
arriver va pas être en meilleure forme
que notre source il ya en fait une chose
dont nous devons discuter
qu'est ce que c'est ton père a laissé sa
porte ouverte
[Musique]
et toi seul est ce qu'une seule fille
sur terre connaît vraiment son père
montre moi ton visage
lauren elisabeth mon nom
t'es pas comme lui on a vite eu meilleur
qu'il ne l'a jamais été
qui êtes-vous j'aime bien penser que je
suis un membre de la famille après
toutes ces années
est ce que papa avait des ennemis dont
je devrais être informé tu sais bien que
c'était pas ça si une personne menacée
notre famille je jetterai son corps dans
la rivière à l'ict avait pas peur de la
vérité
il ya des secrets que j'emporterais dans
ma tente si tu m'apportes que je te
demandais je te promets de tout raconter
vous manquez de moi
parce que mon père me cacher à autre
chose
l'avocate un dentier un politicien qui
te parler la pire d'être édité ton père
n'avait pas le droit de faire ce qu'il a
fait sacrée famille
ça nous prouve rien du tout mais une
fois que je t'aurais tout dit tu
connaîtras la vérité
et là je sais que tu me libère
la vérité doit rester en tête
[Musique]
et environ 15 minutes a eu lieu
l'attentât qui a tué violente explosion
l'abolition plaquant faire face à cette
théorie
bolis de l'espace gemme et qu'il se soit
trouvé les sécurités d'euros
au total me kg de ces quatre qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire alors je serais d'avis
d'aller voir de plus près
je crois qu'il s'agit du fugitif
facebook
[Musique]
on peut s'attendre à d'autres menaces
encore figure
dis moi ce que tu veux
pratique de montreuil des prêts dans 70
tout exploser
j'ai compté sur ses jeux comprennent
clairement
c'est là que tout le monde
là d'où je viens il ya des veilles de tu
vois tu prends quelques jours je te
prend quelque chose
la police est bien suivez mêmes règles
et pas tu pourrais me laisser prendre ta
voiture un soir cette fois qui fait ça
un toit situé commence aujourd'hui à
l'école de prise il s'en sortira très
bien papiers du véhicule
ce vaccin
je vais parler sans détours d'après les
résultats de l'enquêté les policiers
impliqués ne feront l'objet d'aucune
poursuite
ils disent que si jay avait une arme et
avait accès à tous les dossiers
provisoire mon fils a été tué par le
même policier qui a tué le tiens
j'aimerais savoir ce que vous comptez
faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue à creissels den bonjour nous
sommes nouveaux vlad et barnabas t pêche
[Musique]
dans un lieu magique crise felden abri
depuis plus de sept cents ans l'école de
magie la plus réputée de toute la
planète
entouré d'une forêt obscure vous pouvez
marcher pendant des jours vous sortirez
toujours par l'endroit où vous êtes
entré des êtres enchanté votre septième
année est une année magique c'est
l'année où vous allez accueillir votre
héritage familial
et trois amis extraordinaire je
m'appelle vlad un vampire qui supportent
pas le sens je suis fait une fée qui a
peur de voler moi c'est wolf un loup
garou tient une allergie aux poils vont
devoir accomplir leur plus grande
mission après de nombreuses luc viendra
le temps où le mâle contrats pour des
prunes à salles d'abord puis 3 unis pour
dompter leurs faiblesses sauver le monde
magique
comment fait pour traverser
le fragment de sang
[Musique]
là ces enfants tranquilles
tagro c'est pas le bon surtout pas de
panique magic kids est un peu plus haut
encore j'en ai bien peur way